a horrific shooting in Nashville leaves
three little kids and three adults dead
the victims were students and teachers
at a Christian School the shooter was a
28 year old woman who identified as a
transgender man we don't know much about
the shooter's motives but that has not
stopped people particularly liberals
from Reading from their perennial script
to blame guns and the Second Amendment
were the evil actions of criminals
more information is coming to light by
the hour and we will get into a lot of
it today
but even if we didn't know anything at
all about this shooter we would know
that the fault could not lie with the
Second Amendment and guns guns which
have been around for about a thousand
years
guns have become more lethal since the
11th century when they were invented
there's no question about that
but guns actually have not become all
that much more lethal they have not
changed all that much over the past
Century machine guns were invented in
the 1880s the Tommy Gun was invented in
1918. those guns are much deadlier than
anything ordinary civilians can get
their hands on today
no over the past 100 years guns have not
changed much at all
our conceptions of mental health on the
other hand and spiritual reality and
political institutions
have all transformed almost beyond
recognition
but very few people in power are willing
to admit that
it's much easier to point fingers
implausibly at the NRA or whatever much
easier and much more dangerous
our Reckless and negligent rulers get
off the hook the root causes of our
social rot remain unaddressed
and we all just wait for the next
predictable tragedy what do we know
about this shooting uh the the police
chief came out yesterday some hours
after the shooting which is right here I
mean we daily wire is in Nashville
Nashville's not a very big town and so
obviously we were tracking this very
very closely here here's what the police
chief had to say
our investigations tell us that she was
a former student at the school I don't
know what grade she's attended or grades
but we do affirmly believe she was the
student there
she does
I didn't identify as transgender yes no
motive at this point has anything
discovered in the apartment or house no
we have a Manifesto we have some
writings that we're going over that
pertain to this day the actual incident
we have a map drawn out of how this was
all going to take place there's right
now a theory of that's that we may be
able to talk about later but it's not
confirmed and so we'll we'll put that
out as soon as we can is there any
reason to believe that how she
identifies
I'm sorry I'm not someone's Michael I
didn't hear you say that again sir is
there any reason to believe that how she
identifies is has any motive for
targeting the school
uh we can give you that at a later time
there is uh some Theory to that we're
investigating all the leads and once we
know exactly we will let you know so
there you have it
you never want to jump to conclusions in
any of these tragedies there's so many
especially the libs but but everybody
feels some impulse to react to any
tragic political event and impose their
political Vision on it so the libs
always do this with the guns totally
implausibly and but the conservatives
here when they heard that it was a woman
or was it a man or it was this name or
was that name daily wire has a rule
generally which is we don't name
Shooters in these situations because we
don't want to give them glory and we
don't want to encourage others uh there
is an exception to that rule in this
case because the name and the way that
naming works is actually a central part
of this story when the news first broke
we were told it was a young woman then
we were told it was a young man then we
were told it was a person named Audrey
then we were told it was a person named
Aiden and it became clear very very
quickly that this is a transgender
identifying person so what does a
transgender identifying person mean does
that mean a man who's pretending to be a
woman does that mean a woman pretending
to be a man does that mean a woman who's
pumped full of testosterone does that
mean a woman who just says that she's we
just we just didn't know it's it's now
become clear that obviously this person
had lots of identity problems and the
police chief is saying yes one of the
theories here that we're pursuing that
seems quite plausible if not likely is
that transgender identity was a
motivating factor here so so the police
chief then goes on for what we know we
know that they're
this was targeted at this Christian
School we know that this person attended
the Christian school but must have
attended that Christian School like 20
years ago she's 28 years old what else
do we know
so Western is a targeted attack
it was
a gender man or woman don't know any
history of mental illness at this time
put a pause right there we're not
allowed to say anything on YouTube
anymore let's just recount what what the
police chief said the police chief said
this is a woman who thinks that she's a
man
followed by yeah we have no evidence of
mental illness at this time
not quite sure how to make sense of
those two statements next to one another
keep going
the investigation is ongoing and I'm
sorry she identifies the transgender man
or woman as a woman
[Music]
was it the only school that was targeted
I I assume the police chief just being a
normal person just misspoke here because
this issue is so Preposterous but the
question was is this a transgender man
or a transgender woman and what's
confusing about this statement is if if
you're a transgender man that means
you're really a woman and if you're a
transgender transgender woman that means
you're really a man so he answered he
said this person identifies as a
transgender woman which would mean that
she's really a man but uh it would
appear from all the available evidence
no she's really a woman who who
identified as a man keep going
it was the only school that was targeted
there was another location that was
mentioned but because of a threat
assessment by the suspect of too much
security they decided not to and that
area was here in Nashville so we're
continuing with that investigation as
well
so this last part not surprising at all
these these would-be shooters always
look for soft targets so if there's a
location where people are armed where
there's a reasonable exploitation that
people might be armed where there's
Professional Security
you're just not going to look at those
places if you're attempting to commit
one of these atrocities
so there was another location there's a
Manifesto we don't have any of that yet
we'll stay tuned
what are the common threads here people
people are saying this is so unusual
because the shooters are usually these
lonely white guys School shooters
and it's a little more complicated than
that if you include
gang-related school shootings or if you
but but there are common threads here
and I I never really thought the common
threads are
it's white people or it's boys or it's
this or it's that what are the common
threads
uh
history of mental illness
common threads are social isolation
common threads are uh uh psychiatric
drugs in many cases not in all cases
obviously but in many cases
the common threads are
broken families we don't know anything
about this woman's family now Maybe This
Woman's family is totally fine we just
don't know
and this happens again and again and
again this happened not that long ago a
Colorado also transgender identifying
teenager shot up a Denver area Charter
School
pretty recently left one student dead
and eight others wounded and the the
Curious timing of this attack is that it
coincides within a few days of a planned
National event called the trans day of
Vengeance according to a national group
contacted at our rights DC April 1st
will be the trans day of Vengeance to
stop the trans-genocide allegedly what
is the transgenocide a hallucination of
people who don't have a very good grip
on reality what is the trans genocide
quote unquote the transgenocide is a
fable made up by Disturbed people to
justify violence against conservatives
and Christians and normal people who
understand that men and women are
different and don't think that we should
let men enter into the women's locker
room and strip down naked so the trans
day of vengeance is supposed to take
place in Washington D.C though some of
the people who are supporting this have
suggested that the trans day of engines
take place outside of daily wire
headquarters
take place in Nashville
the group is run not just by completely
Fringe lunatics
well they might also be French lunatics
but some of them have had mainstream
jobs the group is run in part by a
former Democrat staffer uh Beau belotti
the trans National recruitment director
he's a former staffer for Virginia
Democrats they've raised money
specifically for firearms training
they've called for direct action in
Nashville trans day of Vengeance not the
trans day of Justice
not the day of justice for everybody
Justice is when you give to people that
which they deserve vengeance is not that
vengeance is when you personally take
retribution for a personal slight
perceived or otherwise
and it reminds me of an old proverb that
people variously attribute to all sorts
of thinkers and no one really seems to
know where the proverb comes from but
it's a good one
that is
when you set out for vengeance
dig two graves
dig two graves dig a grave for the
person you want to get Vengeance on and
dig a grave for yourself because that's
how it's going to turn out
certainly how it turned out yesterday
that's how it always turns out though in
the long run
because either the Quest for vengeance
to aggrieve to to
get retribution for a slight real or
perceived will either result in you
being killed or being jailed or it will
result in the destruction of your soul
because
vengeance is mine saith the Lord so do
not take vengeance
it's from Deuteronomy this is from
letter of Saint Paul
do not take Vengeance we want to take
Vengeance all the time
and
we we can't do that
we can't do that because it's very bad
for our souls it's very bad for society
we have a civil authority to exact
Justice and people feel really Justified
in
their own personal Vengeance and they
feel really angry Jeffrey Marsh who is
this a transgender identifying uh social
media person who who speaks directly to
children and asks little children to
message him so they can talk about sex
together Jeffrey Marsh said that
transgender identifying people should be
really angry channel that anger
everybody should be really angry you
only hear this
from Disturbed people generally on the
left if you are channeling your anger
not your sense of justice not your
political action to transform the Civil
authority to it enact Justice in a more
perfect way if you're saying we're going
to go out there when you get Vengeance
you're almost certainly on the wrong
side of things
line from my friend Andrew Cleveland who
says that anger is the devil's cocaine
and it is
and it is and what what do we know about
all of this
we don't know the specific
drugs that this person may or may not
have been on we don't know the
psychiatric help that this person may or
may not almost certainly did not receive
we do not know the nature of the
person's family or Community or
hatred of Christianity perhaps if it's
targeting a Christian School we don't
know any of that
we do know that this stuff is demonic we
do know that
because we strive
against not flesh and blood but against
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places and
when ideas
pervade the culture
that
convince you to deny reality and to
pursue fantasy and the deeper one to
that you pursue fantasy the more Angry
you should become and you will become
because when we live according to lies
we become very frustrated because the
reality doesn't match up with what's in
our minds
that is demonic
that's all
that's all that is we will be moving
into the member block the Nostradamus
membrane segmentum we will be examining
some movies that Mr Davies insists that
I check out the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code null scanner
wlas and check out for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you